[Musique]
merci manuel Capu de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure merci
à vous vous êtes élu de men Loir membrre
du groupe Les Indépendants République et
territoire vice-président de la
commission des finances et vous êtes
membre d'horizon c'est le parti
d'Edouard Philippe on va d'abord dire un
mot sur ce qui s'est passé hier soir en
Belgique cette nouvelle attaque
terroriste de suédois ont été tué est-ce
qu'on rentre dans un cycle de violence
terroriste en Europe ben je crois qu'on
n est jamais sorti euh on a la France a
été attaquée c'est pas la première fois
que la Belgique est attaquée on est dans
un oui dans ce que vous appelez un cycle
de violence on est on est dans une pense
une guerre ouverte avec les terroristes
avec des appuis très forts qui viennent
manifestement de l'étranger et ça s ça
ne s'est jamais arrêté en réalité
comment on y répond est-ce que le
gouvernement est assez ferme hier Gérald
armman a annoncé sur ce cette actualité
le renforcement des contrôles aux
frontières entre la France et la
Belgique est-ce qu'il faut aller plus
loin après l'attaque d'arace les allè
ont demandé la mise en place de l'état
d'urgence je pense pas que d'abord un je
pense qu'on est vraiment dans le temps
pour l'instant du deuil notamment après
l'assassinat lâche du de de Dominique
Bernard professeur à aras là on a une
deux nouvelles victimes si je comprends
bien des suédois en Belgique je pense
qu'il faut d'abord avoir le temps du
deuil le temps du respect des familles
des peuples qui sont agressés ensuite
très rapidement évidemment il faut se
poser la question de savoir si on est
suffisamment armé je pense que
globalement en deh des mesures très
ponctuelles il y a à se réarmer
militairement et moralement vis-à-vis de
ce type de guerre qui nous est mené par
des terroristes mais comme l'a très bien
dit la semaine dernière le président
Claude maluray par des puissances aussi
derrière étrangère qui sont toit à téran
qui sont à Moscou qui peuvent être aussi
en Asie et qui derrière
incite à la haine de notre démocratie de
notre système démocratique à la haine de
notre façon de vivre parce que c'est ça
qui est attaqué c'est notre façon de
vivre c'est notre modèle de démocratie
face à des systèmes beaucoup plus
totalement autoritaires dictatoriaux qui
veulent supprimer la liberté c'est
extrêmement intéressant alors la
Belgique je c'est arrivé cette nuit mais
euh c'est quand même effectivement
semble-t-il parce que les Suédois
avaient pris des positions de liberté de
liberté de penser qu'ils sont attaqués
et en France c'est c'est un professeur
de collège qui est attaqué donc c'est
donc le savoir la transmission de nos
libertés qui est attaqué directement par
des actes extrêmement lâches et c'est
là-dessus euh qu'il faut répondre et se
réarmé Gérald haranin a fait le lien
entre l'attaque d'aras et le conflit
entre Israël et le Hamas il a dit hier
que 102 personnes avaient été
interpellées euh depuis l'attaque du 7
octobre pour des actes antisémite est-ce
que l'importation du conflit est là
selon
vous
comme je le disais tout à l'heure à
partir du moment où vous avez des
populations qui seou qui qui enfin qui
qui qui s'associent à ce à ces appels à
la haine incontestablement où il y a un
lien très clairif je pense avec ce qui
se passe en Israël ce qui me permet à
nouveau de enfin je l'ai pas encore fait
chez vous de condamner ce qui s'est
passé en
Israël je ne pensais pas personnellement
qu'on pourrait revoir le le type de de
de nettoyage ethnique que l'on a vu
notamment à à aadour surglan en France
on a le même type pendant la Seconde
Guerre mondiale on a eu le même type de
choses qui se sont passées en Israël
c'est totalement
ahurissant totalement plus que choquant
et évidemment euh il faut condamner ces
agressions qui sont d'une d'une lâcheté
ignable et qui encore une fois sont là
uniquement pour déclencher la guerre
pour déclencher des représailles pour
euh entraîner le monde Israël laabord
mais le monde entier ensuite et les
démocraties dans une spirale de guerre
le Sénat veut mettre à l'ordre du jour
demain soir une proposition de
résolution pour condamner les crimes du
Hamas et soutenir les Israéliens la
majorité sénatoriale dit que le
gouvernement ne souhaite pas inscrire
cette résolution à l'ordre du jour
est-ce que vous soutenez cette
initiative du alors moi je n'ai c'est
vous qui me l'avez appris donc je n'ai
vu ni la résolution ni la demande
d'inscription de résolution et encore
moins la réponse du gouvernement donc je
peux absolument pas vous répondre sur ce
point que le Sénat débatte de ça c'est
même pas un débat c'est je n'ai pas de
doute sur le fait que le Sénat dans son
entièreté
soutient le peuple
israélien face à l'agression que comme
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure qui est sans
précédent dans son histoire est-ce que
ça doit être fait dans le cadre d'une
résolution que je n'ai pas vu et àqu à
laquelle personnellement j'ai pas encore
été associé
manifestement peut-être je ne sais pas
ce qui est certain c'est que le Sénat
est
derrière le peuple israélien qui a subi
une agressession particulièrement lâche
on va revenir sur cette attaque d'arace
et cet hommage qui a été rendu hier à
Dominique Bernard et à l'ensemble des
enseignants ça fait la Une de nombreux
quotidiens régionaux ce matin dont le
vote chez vous à anger au Courrier de
l'Ouest où on va bonjour Yv TREC Duran
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous reporter
politique au Courrier de l'Ouest et vous
revenez Yve dans vos pages sur ce double
hommage à ang à Dominique Bertrand mais
aussi à Samuel Patti
oui oui bah évidemment c'était c'était
l'événement du jour hier donc c'est
c'est l'ouverture du journal ce matin
vous disiez monsieur Capu que qu'il y
avait le temps du deuil et qu'il fallait
prendre le temps de la réflexion
néanmoins deux questions se posent très
rapidement plus d'un professeur sur deux
admet se se restreindre dans les propos
qu'il peut tenir en classe de peur de
choquer et on voit que l'entrée dans les
lycées dans un d'un point de vue plus
pratique et se fait trop facilement
alors est-ce qu'il faut qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire pour sécuriser les
professeurs dans leur enseignement et
comment garantir aussi la sécurité des
élèves des personnels et cetera est-ce
qu'il faut rajouter des porti que
faut-il
faire c'est une très bonne question
monsieur TRC Duran
euh il y a des efforts de sécurisation
évidemment qui doivent être fait je
quand j'étais élu à la villedanger on
avait déjà mis en en place des
sécurisations pour toutes les écoles de
la ville d'Anger je pense qu'il faut
effectivement vérifier que cette
sécurisation est faite dans les écoles
dans les collèges et dans les lycées
mais on ne mettra pas un policier
derrière chaque professeur c'est ça qui
est horrible dans cette dans cette
attaque dans cette agression c'est le
fait que les professeurs qui sont sans
défense en réalité puissent être ciblés
et sans aucune raison de façon
totalement anonyme donc un évidemment il
faut renforcer la sécurité ça doit être
fait faut faut faut vérifier que partout
on ne rentre pas comme dans un moulin
dans les écoles mais deuxièmement ce
qu'il faut c'est de la fermeté à l'égard
de tous les actes qui qui peuvent
paraître êtref qui sont le commencement
de
manifestation de menace islamiste ou de
remise en cause de nos institutions de
nos valeurs républicaine de la liberté
de de l'égalité de la fraternité et ça
je crois qu'il faut être d'E extrême
vigilance et d'une fermeté absolue face
et le Gérald d'Anin l'a très bien dit et
on verra ce qui s'est passé pendant la
minute de silence dans tout je suis
assez confiant sur sur anger moi j'étais
au Sénat je n'y étais pas mais je suis
assez confiant sur l'esprit de
modération et de respect des angevin
mais vous savez il a eu des incidents
par le passé il faut être extrêmement
ferme vis-à-vis des incidents et des
provocations on mettra jamais un
policier derrière chaque enseignant
c'est effectivement extrêmement
malheureux que les enseignants et j'ai
lu comme comme vous les les enquêtes qui
disent que deux enseignants sur trois ce
sont autoccensure particulièrement chez
les professeurs d'histoire géographie
mais on le voit avec
l'agression de Dominique Bernard il n'y
a pas que les professeurs d'histoire
géographie parce que ce qui est
incroyable dans cette dernière affaire
c'est que Dominique Bernard n'a à ma
connaissance l'enquête va le démontrer
enfin va le dire ou pas il y a aucune
raison de l'agresser c'est un professeur
agrégé de littérature il y a aucune
raison particulière de l'agresser a
priori il est agressé uniquement pour ce
qu'il représente c'est-à-dire le trans
la transmission du
savoirit sur le chemin du terroriste ou
aussi sans doute ouais mais par rapport
au fait que que que les profs se sentent
obligés de s'autocensurer il ils l'ont
admis hier en parlant aux élèves quand
ils les ont accueillis hier matin c'est
un problème alors certes on peut pas
mettre un policier derrière chaque
professeur néanmoins il y a une
confiance à rétablir et et ça passe
aussi sans doute par des mesures
pratiques alors euh le le filtrage dans
les lycées aujourd'hui même à anger s'il
y a eu des efforts de fait dans les
écoles on peut y rentrer très facilement
alors est-ce qu'il y a des gros
investissements à faire là-dessus
peut-être moi je suis ouvert à toutes
solutions c'est c'est c'est Gabriel Atal
aussi c'est ce qu'il a dit il va
rencontrer les collectivités il est
ouvert à toutes les solutions faut
regarder la
faisabilité et peut-être filtrer
davantage à l'entrée pour qu'il n'y ait
que que les professeurs et que les
élèves qui rentrent avec notamment des
porties c'est peut-être une solution
mais encore une fois je pense que c'est
c'est je comprends
l' je pense que c'est vraiment un
changement de mentalité aussi il faut
vraiment lutter contre c au cœur au
racin même de cette difficulté qui qui
puisse naître dans l'esprit de certains
l'idée même d'assassiner lâchement un
enseignant c'est c'est je crois là qu'il
faut
éradiquer qui sutensure est-ce que là
c'est une alerte la semaine dernière
gérardch disait que toute la classe
politique avait été faible sur les
attentes à la laïcité sur la question du
communautarisme il a eu raison moi je
pense que je me souviens très très bien
après les attentats du Bataclan il y
avait une volonté extrêmement ferme de
de de condamner et de rester ferme sur
ses valeurs avec le temps on oublie très
vite et on se relâche
forcément cette nouvelle alerte nous
montre qu'il faut rester extrêmement
vigilant extrêmement ferme et je crois
que Gabriel Atal a montré qu'il était
extrêmement ferme
notamment sur tout signe extérieur qui
pourrait être considéré comme une comme
une comme une atteinte à la à la laïcité
de la même façon il faut rester
extrêmement ferme contre toute forme
d'atteinte au principes républicains qui
sont les nôtres dans nos
établissements je pense que c'est ça une
des réponses merci merci beaucoup la une
professeur tué à aras l'hommage et
l'émotion c'est à la Une de votre
journal merci beaucoup Yv TREC Duron
d'avoir été avec nous on va continuer à
parler de ce sujet et des questions que
cette attaque à aras pose notamment sur
la présence en France de l'assaillant il
y a le projet de loi immigration qui
arrive au Sénat dans une quinzaine de
jours est-ce qu'il faut encore plus le
durcir pour que des profils comme
celui-là soi plus facilement
expulsables c'est possible je je je dis
je ne dis pas non il faut tirer les
conséquences des agressions qu'on subit
c'est évident je crois surtout qu'il
faut le
voter il faut arrêter de tergiverser il
faut pas ou voilà faut pas boter en
touche
euh ça va dans le bon sens c'est c'est
ça que je veux dire c'est c'est évident
que ça va dans le bon sens ça va dans le
bon sens pourquoi parce que c'est
totalement hallucinant invraisemblable
qu'un type qui aurait dû être expulsé en
2014 soit encore sur le territoire et
donc faut faciliter lesf les capacités
expulsion des personnes qui ont une
obligation de quitter le territoire
c'est
totalement protection pour reprendre
l'expression de Gerald hermanin il faut
lever certaines protections pour
reprendre l'expression de Gal faut
évidemment faut faut diminuer les dél
c'est pas normal que que le qtf elle
date de 2014 et elle a toujours pas été
appliqué c'est pas normal c'est pas
normal qu'on puisse pas expulser des
gens qui sont dans cette situation là et
peut-être qu'il faut renforcer peut-être
la question qui se pose c'est est-ce
qu'on peut si je comprends bien c'est
parce qu'il avait moins de 13 ans au
moment o où il est arrivé en France est
arrivé en France peut-être qu'il faut se
poser aussi la question de renvoyer chez
eux des des des personnes de moins de 13
ans c'est tout à fait possible ça ça
pourrait être un élément à à rajouter
compte tenu du contexte compte tenu de
notre connaissance actuelle dans le dans
la proposition de loi mais la
proposition de loi elle permet déjà
d'accélérer et de faciliter les
sanctions donc déjà ça c'est mieux que
rien donc vous dites r il faut qu'on
trouve un accord eux ils ont une ligne
rouge hein vous la connaissez c'est la
question de titre de séjour dans les
méti en tenstion est-ce que là-dessus
vous êtes prêt à accepter que ça soit
sorti du texte que ça passe par une
circulaire c'est le le compromis qui
semble se décider à titre personnel je
seraai pas totalement opposé parce que
on parlera peut-être du travail après
mais moi j'ai toujours été un peu
surpris de de de cette de la
régularisation de travailleurs qui sera
en situation irrégulière
euh je pense qu'il faut que donc là vous
êtes quand même un peu d'accord avec les
républ je pense vous savez moi je suis
un adepte de de l'ordre dans la rue et
de l'ordre dans les compes vous le savez
madame Mancini et et je pense que
j'entends très bien la demande des
employeurs d'avoir des salariés et il
faut effectivement trouver de des
salariés pour arriver au plein emploi ça
c'est tout à fait d'accord en revanche
donner une prime à au travail clandestin
illégal en tant que praticien du droit
en tant que en tant que législateur
j'avoue que ça me pose une toute petite
difficulté il y a un équilibre à trouver
et ça ne me dérangerait pas que cet
équilibre
bascule dans dans dans la dans la
circularisation comme vous dites de
cette problématique un dernier mot avant
de parler des finances publiques Gérald
armanin qui veut aussi expulser les
fichiers S pour radicalisation les
fichers étrangers est pour
radicalisation ce qui nécessiterait de
s'affranchir de quelques règles
européennes vous dites c'est pas grave
il faut le faire ce que disent les
républicains d'ailleurs c'est plus
complexe à mon avis je pense pas qu'on
puisse réagir sous sous le sous l'effet
de l'émotion
euh juridiquement vous savez que je suis
avocat
euh j'imagine que c'est extrêmement
compliqué à faire mais là encore je ne
faut rien s'interdire et s'il faut
améliorer la loi de ce point de vue-là
faut sans doute le faire c'est vrai que
la situation dans laquelle nous nous
nous nous retrouvons avec un un Russe
enin un réfugié ingouche si je comprends
bien qui manifestement ne se sentait pas
très très très intégré dans not notre
société à tel point qu'il va
décider d'aller assassiner un innocent
ça c'est plus tolérable donc il faut
qu'on trouve des solution pour que ces
gens-là qui n'ont rien à faire sur notre
territoire rentrre sur leur territoire
faut troutionné par l'Union européenne
faut faut trouver faut trouver une
solution y compris au niveau
européen je pense que les événements de
cette nuit nous montrre que c'est
l'Europe qui est attaqué c'est
l'ensemble à mon sens c'est même
l'ensemble des démocraties les
Américains sont beaucoup plus que nous
sur sur la sur la façon d'entrer sur
leur territoire je parle même pas des
Australiens démocratie au sens large il
faut regarder les modèles du monde
entier on va parler de la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
puisque le Sénat l'a voté hier soir
objectif de ce texte réduire le déficit
pour le faire passer sous la barre des 3
% mais le Sénat a voté sa propre version
pour accélérer les choses on va voir les
temps forts de cette séance avec
Alexandre
poussa
bonjour Alex bonjour Arian bonjour
Emmanuel cap bonjour Alors Alex d'abord
quel est l'objectif de cette
programmation des finances publiques
alors l'objectif de ce texte c'est de
fixer la trajectoire budgétaire de la
France d'ici à 2027 c'est un texte qui
d'ailleurs avait été débattu il y a 1 an
et rejeté par l'Assemblée nationale
alors le gouvernement a remis ce texte
sur la table un an plus tard et cette
fois-ci l'exécutif a utilisé le 493 pour
passer en force cette loi de
programmation des finances publiques à
l'Assemblée nationale avant le débat au
Sénat hier alors quelle trajectoire
budgétaire propose le gouvernement et
bien il souhaite un déficit public qui
arriverait en dessous de la barre des 3
% de notre produit intérieur brut en
2027 à la fin du quinquena il serait aux
alentours de 2,7 % la dette de la France
serait abaissée à 108 % de notre
richesse nationale produite et pour le
gouvernement et bien cette trajectoire
c'est une question de crédibilité
écoutez le ministre des comptes
publiques nous devons d'abord nous
montrer crédiible vis-à-vis des Français
qui ont besoin de connaître le chemin
que nous allons emprunter et de savoir
comment nous allons financer dans les
années qui viennent les services publics
et l'investissement dans les priorités
d'avenir il s'agit également d'assurer
notre crédibilité vis-à-vis de nos
partenaires européens à cette fin nous
traduisons les objectifs fixés dans le
programme de stabilité mais aussi il est
essentiel que la France démontre sa
capacité à se donner un cap une
trajectoire et un véritable cadre pour
le redressement de ces finances
publiques est-ce que ça convient à la
majorité de la droite et du centre du
Sénat Alex et non les sénateurs les
républicains les sénateurs centristes
estiment que cette trajectoire
budgétaire n'est pas assez ambitieuse
que le gouvernement ne prévoit pas assez
d'économie on va écouter le rapporteur
général du budget Jean-François
hon monsieur le ministre à force de ne
pas faire ce que vous dites et de ne pas
dire ce que vous faites non seulement
les comptes de la France ne sont pas
tenus mais les Français ne s'y
retrouvent pas vous ne priorisez rien en
annonçant d'ailleurs vouloir financer
tout ou presque à chaque jour une
annonce nouvelle dont l'unité de valeur
est souvent le milliard vous parlez de
sérieux budgétaire et vous faites
exploser la dette de la France tout en
renvoyant au parlementaires vous venez
de le faire encore la responsabilité de
faire des économies c'est le monde à
l'envers et la majorité de droite et du
centre du Sénat a donc voté une version
différente qui va plus vite dans la
diminution des déficits pour passer la
barre des 3 % dès 2025 et pour amamener
le déficit de la France à 1,7 % de notre
PIB en 2027 cela nécessiterait de faire
des dizaines de milliards d'euros
d'économie les sénateurs veulent
également que l'effort financier soient
le même pour l'État et pour les
collectivités locales et il souhait
aussi baisser le nombre de
fonctionnaires d'État avec une
diminution de 5 % du nombre de ces
fonctionnaires une mesure qui n'a pas du
tout plus à la gauche dans le débat
regardez 5 % et ça nous a été expliqué
c'est 100000 emplois publics en moins
c'est c'était effectivement le droit fil
du programme d'un candidat qui a pas
bien réussi s'appelit François Fillon en
2017 qu'est-ce que cela signifie il y a
trop d'agent à la Banque de France pour
aider les particuliers en situation de
surendettement il y a trop d'agents à
Pôle emploi pour lutter contre le
chômage ou j'ai une formation il y a
trop d'agents l'Office national des
forêts pour lutter contre le feu et le
réchauffement climatique et comme la
gauche le gouvernement s'est déclaré
défavorable à la version votée par la
majorité de droite et du centre du Sénat
mais les sénateurs espèrent que le
gouvernement au final va retenir
quelques mesures inspirées par le Sénat
dans la version qui devrait être sans
doute adoptée une nouvelle fois au 493 à
l'Assemblée nationale Emmanuel Capu les
sénateurs du parti horizon d'Édouard
Philippe ont voté cette version euh de
la majorité de droite euh sénatoriale
contre la viille gouvernement est-ce
qu'il y a euh finalement une différence
entre le parti d'Édouard Philippe et
Renaissance le parti d'Emmanuel Macron
sur cette question de la rigueur
budgétaire il y a il y a des
particularités de chaque membre de la
majorité euh présidentielle euh
évidemment sinon il y aurait qu'un seul
parti unique vous savez que Horizon a
une particularité loyale et libre mais
aussi je l'ai je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
très attaché à l'ordre dans les comptes
euh et donc là en l'espèce et puis il y
a pas que horizon il y a aussi au sein
du groupe Les Indépendants il y a la
moitié d'horizon la moitié qui ne sont
pas horizon nous on est extrêmement
cohérent dans mon groupe la les - 5 % de
la masse salariale de la fonction
publique c'était un amendement que nous
nous avions déposé en fait si c'est dans
le texte c'est parce qu'en première
lecture l'amendement des indépendants a
été adopté donc on va pas faire la fine
bouche et revenir sur nos propre
proposition pourquoi pour c'est un parce
que au dehors des postures en dehors de
des des effets de tribune derrière ce
qu'il faut retenir c'est que la loi de
programmation contrairement à
l'Assemblée nationale elle a été votée
elle a été votée avec ce qui est notre
rôle du Sénat c'est ça la différence si
vous voulez pas une question de parti ou
ou ou pas de parti c'est une question de
quel est l'intérêt du Sénat le Sénat il
est là pour améliorer pour amender les
textes et au final pour les voter et
c'est ce qu'il a démontré hier derrière
les effets de tribune qu'a fait le Sénat
il a voter la programmation de finances
publiques
20232027 c'est une bonne chose pourquoi
ça va nous permettre de toucher les
subventions européennes ça va nous
permettre d'avoir une trajectoire c'est
vrai qu'on l'a un petit peu durci je je
moi j'ai voté le texte donc on a on a on
a durci on a durci pour la fonction
publique parce que c'était notre
proposition des indépendants pourquoi
parce que le gouvernement aujourd'hui
propose la stabilité mais on sait bien
et donc c'est un dialogue constructif
avec le entre le Sénat et le
gouvernement on sait bien que quand on
vise la stabilité bah au final on arrive
à l'augmentation donc nous ce qu'on dit
c'est vise on Mo 5 on verra où on arit
c'est un texte qui n'est non
contraignant donc au moins fixons-nous
des objectifs plus ambitieux et et ça
marchera voilà donc effectivement on
aurait pu s'abstenir on a voté pour
pourquoi parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
choses qui nous paraissent une bonne
chose et pour répondre très précisément
à votre question c'est vrai que je pense
que les sénateurs horizon sont
extrêmement soucieux de l'ordre dans les
comptes et donc de de notre déficit de
la réduction de notre déficit public et
donc est-ce que vous demandez au
gouvernement dans la version finale de
cette trajectoire budgétaire qui sera
adoptée à l'Assemblée nationale sans
doute au 493 vous demandez au
gouvernement de prendre une version plus
rigoureuse comme celle qui a été votée
au Sénat il y a ben c'est le rôle c'est
le rôle de notre démocratie de notre
système de bicamérisme il y a la navette
vous pensez qu'il va le faire parce que
le ministre dit que c'est pas crédible
comme trajecto on verra on verra on
verra ce qu' ce qu'il peut garder ce
qu'il souhaite garder je suis convaincu
qu'il y a des choses qui qui qui qui
resteront il y a des déjà eu des
améliorations notamment on en a pas
parlé mais pour les
collectivités locales et notamment pour
les conseils départementaux il y a déjà
dans l'objectif de réduction de la
dépense publique un certain nombre de
mesures qui ont été prises notamment
l'exclusion des allocations de
individuel social qui ont été retiré
pour tenir compte et on a demandé à ce
qu'il y en ait plus encore qui soit
retiré pour tenir compte là encore j'ai
déposé un amendement qui était le même
que celui des socialistes et le même que
euh celui euh de la majorité LR du Sénat
parce que on va parfois dans le même
sens dans la défense des collectivités
territorial vous parliez des
fonctionnaires d'État votre amendement
qui proposait euh de diminuer le nombre
de fonctionnaires Emmanuel Macron avait
renoncé à ce projet après la crise des
gilets jaunes pourquoi remettre cette
mesure sur la table est-ce que ça ne va
pas aggraver les fractures du pays vous
avez raison euh c'était notre collègue
Pascal Savelli s'est trompé quand il a
parlé de François Fillon François Fillon
parlait de mo-s 500000 et c'était bien
Emmanuel Macron qui parlait de moin
120000 et donc en plus il y a une
logique effectivement donc d'une
certaine façon notre amendement restait
totalement fidèle à à à à à la promesse
de 2017 j'entends j'entends évidemment
c'est c'est une discussion chacun
donne sa façon de voir les choses
ensuite on verra Infiné effectivement je
crains que les les députés renoncent à
exercer leur pouvoir et que ce soit au
gouvernement de trancher dans la limite
des capacités qu'il qu'il verra à ce
moment-là ce qui est important pour nous
c'est de rappeler euh ce ce ce ce qui
nous apparaît bon euh pour la France
euh vu du Sénat merci Alex à tout à
l'heure à tout à l'heure merci Emmanuel
Capu le budget arrive bientôt au Sénat
vous reviendrez nous voir avec grand
plaisir les les débats vont être
effectivement passionnants merci
beaucoup merci Emmanuel Capu d'avoir été
notre invitép